super grateful and lucky to have him as
a coach
hey alex congrats uh case from las vegas
son what did uh being a captain this
last year at alabama mean to you do you
think did that help you through that
process do you think it helped teams uh
kind of be
ultimately the raiders of course be
attracted to you in the draft
i mean uh to be honest um titles don't
really
you know what i mean um mean much to me
titles but i just know like the effect
that i had on my teammates
and uh my peers it meant a lot to me for
them to like you know appoint me
essentially like a high level you know
what i mean like being a captain
so i feel like uh of course it was a
great honor you know what i mean i got
to put my handprint in my footprint and
uh
any charms on campus that's going to be
there forever
and i feel like it definitely uh helped
me through this pre-drive process
because
it showed the teams and the coaches and
gm's like how much effect that i can
have on my player
i mean on my team and the type of player
that i am
you know what i mean and what i'm all
about because it was a
team voted not coach appointed so to
have that respect from my peers and
like it meant a lot alex
levi edwards with raiders.com welcome to
the desert of course
you already have a couple of teammates
already over here uh and josh jacobs and
henry ruggs that you're probably
familiar with uh
how excited are you to be able to play
with those guys that you've already had
success with
and have they kind of put you on what
life is like out here in las vegas
uh i'll talk to him a little bit but i'm
more than excited for this opportunity
you know what i mean
reuniting with josh jacobs and uh henry
ruggs they
and lester cotton as well like they all
know what it takes to win
you know what i mean they they know what
it means to be a champion so just like
reuniting them hopefully we can um bring
a super bowl to las vegas
hi alexa levi damien from usa today i'm
just
kind of wondering um you know we just
you talked earlier in this conversation
about the the rankings of where people
had you slotted and whatnot
when you were watching that and based on
the you know the fact that you your
accolades that you were able to collect
at alabama did that
did that annoy you upset you in any way
were you you know angry and eager to
kind of prove those rankings wrong
i mean it definitely put a chip on my
shoulder you know what i mean it
bothered me a little bit but
at the same time i'm not like i'm not a
media guy i'm not the type of dude to
get like
caught up in all that garbage because i
know what my films had about me
and the gm and the scouts they know that
as well you know what i mean so um
i'm just grateful that um you know they
watched that film and
um you know they saw me as
good enough to be this 17th overall pick
you know what i mean so
i'm more than excited to get to the
program and um and prove them right
not necessarily like prove the haters
the people who made all the mock drives
and all this stuff wrong but to prove
myself
and to raid this organization right
because i'm thankful and grateful for
them
alex when you go to a place like alabama
you're going to have to compete there's
star players all over the place
including offensive line
how important was it for you to get on
the field early but then also looking
back
playing some guard and tackle in terms
of your development and what you were
able to show the nfl playing both of
those positions
definitely it was important for me to
play early uh i didn't get to start as a
freshman but
um i accepted my role on the team
when like i didn't start as a freshman i
was a backup and i just got in my bag
and tried to uh
perfect my craft as much as i could you
know what i mean
and um just uh coming from a place like
that
and being around a lot of competition um
i feel like
that only drove me to be like even
greater because uh i'm
super competitive at nature you know
what i mean so i feel like it was a
it was a great fit it was a great a
great spot to be in you know what i mean
just like by nature
and the nature of the program so i feel
like it's a great fit and
as far as me playing uh tackle and guard
uh you know when uh
my sophomore year i was one of the best
five so i had to find a spot on that
line
and i feel like uh playing guard and
playing tackle you know what i mean that
just showed my
versatility and competitiveness as an
athlete and that's an old lineman you
know what i mean
um being on the field by any means uh
sacrificing
or my team and just um just being a dog
and competing in
being on the field to contribute to wins
so
alex jerry macdonald from the bay area
news group um
could you tell us about where you are
who you were with uh who who made the
call to you was it coach gruden and
coach miak
and you're wearing the raiders had do
you did you have 32 hats
were you ready for anybody to pick you
yes sir i did have
32 hats i was ready for anybody to pick
me and uh coach gruen he definitely did
call me
and i'm in pensacola florida i'm on the
beach it's my hometown and i was
surrounded by my uh friends and family
and uh
i couldn't thank them more for being him
for being here and supporting me
and it was a great overall experience
and a great drive
alex one last question from my
conversation with butch jones is he said
that the most underrated characteristic
you have is leadership
did mike and mayok and john gruden talk
to you about coming in and even though
you'll be a rookie just the leadership
you can offer
oh we did touch on it a little bit but
um not much
but uh i just want to say thank you to
coach jones
because as far as being a leader that
was definitely one thing that i wanted
to change about myself going from my
junior to my senior year
just trying to affect those around me
you know what i mean in a positive way
and always harping on the things that we
needed to do to be champions
and uh i feel like that went well by the
results of my senior season
when we came out to national
championships and looks like we have one
more question willie go ahead
hey willy ramirez with the associated
press in las vegas we go back
two questions you had said that uh you
had all the hats waiting you were
waiting on
on the call that moment you received the
call as you're be as you're watching the
draft but your name's not called there
but you get that call can you just maybe
take us a couple of things that were
said that that overall
that overwhelming feeling maybe the
words that were said to you and
just that exchange once you knew it was
official
i mean um to be honest uh it wasn't
really
overwhelming not that i wasn't excited
and extremely grateful
for the opportunity but um
you know i i controlled what i could
control you know what i mean so i was
ready for like any outcome
i feel like i did the best i could do
and when they called me
and when they called me i was calm i was
uh
ready to go as soon as i got a call i
was like i don't know who this is you
know what i mean but hey it's go
time you know what i mean so i was just
super grateful
elated at the opportunity and uh yeah
that's pretty much it
great thank you for your time alex
appreciate it congratulations sir i
appreciate it
you